manuel merino presidente del congreso
peruano convocó a la junta de portavoces
para programar en las próximas horas las
acciones a efectuar la principal
preocupación de merino es que el
presidente de martín vizcarra con una
medida cautelar ante el tribunal
constitucional bloquee cualquier intento
de vacancia presidencial la estrategia
legal de los asesores del mandatario es
cuestionar el término incapacidad moral
presentarlo como un término ambiguo y
una de las estrategias ha mencionado es
invocar la experiencia del ex presidente
alejandro toledo porque él tuvo una hija
fuera del matrimonio y jamás la
reconoció si no luego de esas
investigaciones y pero el parlamento
jamás le aplicó el término de
incapacidad moral y mucho menos lo
sometió una vacancia presidencial esto
es lo que van a escribir las autoridades
a partir de la demanda que se va a
presentar este lunes ante el tribunal
constitucional háblanos primero de las
certezas francisco y luego de los
posibles escenarios y es que el congreso
deberá votar en un pleno extraordinario
si mantiene o no al mandatario en el
poder conocer a este proceso y qué
escenarios pueden pasar francisco que
tan posee
es que se destituye al presidente
el impeachment al presidente de martín
vizcarra está programado para este
viernes 18 a las 10 de la mañana si el
parlamento consigue los 87 votos el
mandatario deja el cargo y de acuerdo a
la constitución el jefe del parlamento
manuel merino sería el presidente e
investido de los peruanos pero tal como
están las cosas es poco probable que se
consiga los 87 votos por los hechos
demostrados en las últimas horas y todo
va a depender de la política y como en
este país cualquier cosa pero puede
ocurrir va a depender también de las
negociaciones que por un lado efectuó el
presidente de martín vizcarra y por el
otro lado manuel merino al interior de
las bancadas del parlamento